foreign
[Music]
my name is Juliette Morrison and I'm an
assistant professor at University of
California Riverside and I'm in the
department of microbiology and Plant
Pathology and today I will be presenting
exciting results from my group that show
that plural macrophages promote recovery
from influenza
so let's get started
influenza has been with us a very long
time it was described as early as 400 BC
and the major epidemics and pandemics of
influenza have occurred throughout
history
and many experts believe that another
influenza pandemic that could kill
millions of humans is inevitable
there is also a seasonal burden of
seasonal influenza so seasonal influenza
results in three to five million cases
of severe disease and 290 000 to 650 000
deaths annually
there's also a very high economic costs
with 11.2 billion in economic costs per
year in the US related to influenza
like other um respiratory viruses
influenza virus
is transmitted by via droplet
transmission the virus enters the
respiratory tract and attaches to
ciliated epithelial cells lining the
sinuses and Airways
then as the virus replicates the Cilia
are destroyed
mucus cannot be removed and so the
Airways become clogged and stimulate
coughing
and destruction of cilia contribute to
the secondary bacterial pneumonia
infections sinusitis and otitis
now what we study in the Morrison lab is
the host response and what is a host
response it is the reaction of a living
system to a stimulus
and the the Z severity of a viral
illness is determined by the interplay
between the virus and the host response
if you have too little of a response
that's bad because then you the virus
will replicate
um unrestricted and that will cause a
lot of tissue damage and so you get
disease but you can have too much of a
response and that is also bad because if
the responses to exuberance you end up
with a whole bunch of
other tissue damage damage of healthy
tissue and this can also lead to disease
so one of the goals of the Morrison lab
is to develop post-targeted viral
Therapeutics
and so what we envision
and imagine is that there is a balance
between viruses and the host response
and so we look at it as a seesaw and so
what I'm showing you here is an image of
children on a seesaw and they are
representing viruses versus the host
response and in this image we have the
viruses and they're winning so you can
see one red arrow here where the viruses
are clearly winning but if you were to
look at the other red arrow pointing to
that child in the red hat
if we were to just move him over
slightly we could balance that seesaw
and that's what we're aiming to do we
don't want to just dampen the whole
immune response we would like to find
um specific cell types and Pathways that
we could Target that could
allow us to tweak the immune response so
that we can still fight the viruses but
prevent the negative consequences of an
exuberant and overly exuberant immune
response
and so for one of our cases that we're
interested in is influenza and one of
the things that we were trying to do is
to figure out how we can take a host
targeted strategy for treating influenza
infections and to and to do this we went
ahead and compared the host response to
different influenza viruses and so we
asked the question is there a long gene
expression signature that can
distinguish mild and severe influenza
so to do so we use two data sets
um
um one here from
an older data set that I published in
2014 and another similarly designed one
from 2012 from Jos I said Al
and what we have here are mice that have
been bouncy mice that have been infected
with different strains of influenza a
wide range in fact so we have h7n9 Avian
Influenza h7n7
we have h5n1
we have the pandemic H1N1 from 2009
and then in the just sites at all we
have a range of H1N1 seasonal influenzas
the 2009
um H1N1 pandemic strain and we also have
the notorious 1918 reconstructed
um influenza so we have a wide range of
viruses with a wide range of outcomes so
I'm pointing you to this graph here
where on the y-axis we have percent body
weight and on the x-axis we have days
post infection and you can see that
these that the outcomes fall into
roughly three groups so we have here our
seasonal flu viruses that cause on mild
disease the the animals lose a little
bit of weight but then they recover
then we also have some animals that lose
a lot of weight but then do recover
and then we have other animals that lose
so much weight that they have to be
euthanized or they
um die naturally and these animals fall
into our group that are infected with
our Avian Influenza viruses or the 1918
influenza
so we have this wide range of viruses
and then from in both of these studies
we also have viral titers we have a
histopathology data and we have gene
expression data from whole lungs
and the aim for this study was to take
all this data put them together and to
identify tissue signatures and
predictive markers and that's what we
did
so we found that pathogenic viruses
induce a specific Gene signature so let
me walk you through these data
so here I have this large heat map and I
want to point you to the top of the heat
map here where I'm showing you percent
weight loss so I have all of these
viruses here lined up from left to right
from least pathogenic to most pathogenic
based on percent weight loss
so you can see um that line up there and
then
you can see that on the
the left we have different
um
modules
that um different Gene modules and you
can see here let me move forward
that in one module inflammatory red
module we can see that with for the
inflammatory responses that we have more
um expression of inflammatory genes in
with viruses that are more pathogenic so
viruses on the right
we also found that
for genes that are involved in metabolic
responses and tissue repair mechanisms
they are more they are less expressed in
in the lungs of animals that were
infected with the highly pathogenic
viruses and the 1918 strains
what was very interesting to us though
were these modules in the middle these
lipid metabolism coagulation signaling
oxidative stress responses Etc
um that were more highly expressed in
the the
lower pathogenic viruses versus the
higher pathogenic viruses
and so we asked the question what was
actually going on there
what what are the what cell types are
actually driving these differences and
we know that these are long whole lungs
so the lung is made up of a a mixture of
different cell types we have epithelial
cells we have different immune cells
which
lung cells are actually responsible for
these transcriptomic differences
to get a feel for which cells are
actually responsible for this we decided
to take a systems level View and so we
employed this um tissue
um deconvolution algorithm called the
digital cell quantifier or dcq and what
dcq does is to take genome-wide gene
expression data like what we have for
whole lungs
and combines that with an immune cell
compendium from imagen which has a bunch
of
um different immune cell types
and then takes this puts it together so
that it can infer uh
in Vivo Global Dynamic change in the
immune cell quantities within this
complex tissue like the lung
and so in using dcq along with
regression analysis we were able to
identify lung populations that correlate
with weight loss
for example so once again I want you to
take a look at the top of this figure
where we have our weight loss so we
still have our our
um strains here lined up from uh from
left to right we have our least
pathogenic to our most pathogenic
outcomes
and we see that there are various immune
cell types that are correlated with
disease severity for example we have
granulocytes that are shown that are
predicted to be enriched in animals that
have more severe disease outcomes some
more weight loss and this is actually
known in the literature that when you
have more neutrophils in the lung you um
are you have more severe disease
outcomes
we also dcq also predicted that there
would be less alveolar macrophages in
animals that had more severe outcomes
which is also known in the literature
but we weren't interested in using
um dcq as uh validation tool we were
interested in using it as a tool for
discovery
so we were very interested in a
particular population that had popped up
and that we had never seen before
and that population was this small
peritoneal macrophage population
um that we saw here and it was very
curious to us because we asked what are
peritoneal macrophages even doing in the
lung
more importantly what we noticed is that
this population was predicted to be only
in animals that survived infection so
this was very exciting to us here's our
population of macrophages they're
supposed to be in the lung but only in
animals that survive influenza infection
what's going on here
so this is where the hypothesis
generation begins
so we asked ourselves peritoneal
macrophages where are these found well
these are found in the peritoneal cavity
and so what is a peritoneal cavity well
the peritone health cavity is a serosal
cavity and the cirrhosal cavities are
the protein peritoneal cavity which
surrounds our abdominal organs the
pleural cavity which surrounds our lungs
and the pericardial cavity that
surrounds our heart and so these are
fluid-filled cavities that protect and
cushion our organs but also contain
immune cells primarily macrophages and
so because of the relationship between
the pleural cavity and the
peritoneal cavity we hypothesize then
that what we were actually seeing in the
lungs was actually plural macrophages
and not necessarily peritoneal
macrophages
so serosal cavities contain similar cell
populations
um they contain macrophages and serosal
macrophages are divided into two
populations small macrophages
which are MHC Class 2 positive at 480
Negative they are smaller than the large
macrophages and they also are about 10
of the macrophage population
we also have our large several cell
macrophages
and they are MHC plus two negative f4at
positive and they make up about 90 of
the population and they are larger in
size as well
and so we thought perhaps perhaps then
macrophages that we were seeing that
were being predicted to be in the long
in our surviving animals were our small
serosal macrophages and specifically
small plural macrophages so here's our
hypothesis we hypothesize that plural
macrophages were leaving the pleural
cavity
crossing the mesothelial layer and
entering the lung
to do something
perhaps inhibiting influenza replication
or inhibiting damage but doing something
to help promote recovery
um from influenza
so we went ahead and decided to test
this hypothesis and this project was
driven primarily by a student a graduate
student in the lab James Stumpf
and he started off by finding testing
whether or not we could label plural
macrophages in Vivo
and it's notoriously difficult to label
to do intramural in injections but we've
actually worked on a very good technique
and so James was able to intro um to
inject
the um inject the pleural cavity with um
pkh dye which is uh which specifically
labels phagocytic cells
and then he harvested these from the
mice that have been into a purely
injected
and you can see here in red that the
macrophages have picked up the the dye
so yes we are able to label these um
macrophages and we can do it in Vivo
I also want to show you here what
happens when we um
set up an influenza virus infection
um using our model so here is on
intranasal infection with California 9
which is
um
a strain of um influenza that we use
and you can see here
on our y-axis we have um our percent of
initial body weight and on the x-axis we
have these post infection
and in this particular
um with a particular dose that we use we
have a little weight loss and then we
have recovery
so this is a model of a mild
disease from which the animals recover
so then we ask a question do plural
macrophages traffic to the lungs during
influenza and so
on day one
we intraperally
um inject the pkh dye to to to label the
macrophages and then on day two we do an
intranasal infection with um Kalo 9 or
we do a PBS control
then the lungs are harvested on days 6 9
and 12 post infection
and then they are used for flow
cytometry
I just want to outline how we sort our
plural macrophages as well as our long
macrophages
so for our plural macrophage sorting
we're taking our single cells that are
alive
and then we are looking at CD 115 and CD
level B positive cells and this is our
all of our plural macrophages
and then we are distinguishing them into
small plural macrophages like their MHC
class to positive and large pleural
macrophages if they're f480 positive
now for long macrophages we're taking
our singlets that are alive and
we consider them macrophages if they're
multi-k-positive and cd64 positive
and then we are
um then differentiating them into two
populations
interstitial macrophages we consider
them interstitial macrophages if they're
cd11 B positive and we consider them
alveolar macrophages if they're Sig like
f positive
so now for the questions do plural
macrophages traffic to the lungs during
influenza
and so here are results for day six day
nine and day 12. I want you to take note
of the axes we have our live cell
numbers
um from our lungs and we are looking
um here at what happens in our
PBS
mice versus our collo9 infected mice
and both of these mice have been
um labeled with pkh intraperally
and you can see here that only in our
California 09 mice do we see the
presence of these pkh positive cells
accumulating and they Peak on day nine
post infection
and also want to
reorient you to the this map that we
have here of the weight loss
um pointing out specifically when weight
loss occurs which is on day six and when
we start seeing weight gain which is on
day nine and so when we're seeing the
accumulation of these plural macrophages
within the lung is when we're actually
seeing the animals starting to regain
weight which would suggest that these
pleural macrophages are involved more in
a in the resolution of the Z in the in
the resolution of disease
we also asked what these pkh positive
lung cells were are they alveolar
macrophages are they interstitial
macrophages and we found that these pkh
positive cells are actually cd11 B
positive indicating that they are
interstitial macrophages they're not
alveolar macrophages they don't have um
Sig like f
we also asked where are these pkh
positive lung cells so here we have some
microscopy images of the lungs
in red we have
um our pkh stained macrophages and in
blue we have dappy which is staining all
the cells
the top panel shows our PBS animals and
so we don't see any red because the
there are no macrophages going into the
the lung and on the bottom panel we have
our collo9 infected animals and you see
the accumulation of these plural
macrophages in the lung
um near to the mesothelia layer so the
little dotted white line there is the
mesothelial layer
so pleural macrophages accumulate in the
lung near the mesothelium
so we then ask do pleural macrophages
influenza outcomes so it's great that
they're going into the lung but are they
even doing anything are they of
are they even important
so
to test this we
did an intra-pural
um injection of quadrinate liposomes so
what this is is that quadronate
basically is a poison and the liposome
will direct this poison specifically to
phagocytic cells
um in the pleural cavity and so when you
inject these quadrinate ribosomes the
pleural macrophages in the pleural
cavity will pick this up and then they
will undergo apoptosis and they'll be
depleted
we also have PBS liposomes as a
as a control
and where the first thing we did was to
look at the levels of virus in our lungs
post infection
and we looked at these three and day six
and we found no difference in the viral
loads in mice that had plural
macrophages versus mice that had that
lacks plural macrophages so there was no
impact on viral replication
and so on our y-axis we have platforming
units per gram
on our x-axis here we have our
um PBS liposomes versus our quadrinates
liposomes
and we also looked at the
at weight loss and so on our y-axis here
we have percent of initial body weights
x-axis we have this post infection and
here we actually see a difference you
can see that we have increased weight
loss in the animals that had the
intrapro intra plural quadrinate
liposome injection
which indicates that
when you deplete the plural macrophages
there is increased weight loss during
influenza virus infection showing that
the pleural macrophages are important
for influenza virus outcomes
and to get to the root of what's going
on here we went ahead and looked at what
was going on with the
the immune cells in the lung
so when we looked at the total long City
45 cells so all the leukocytes in the
cells in the lungs we didn't see much of
a difference
um in the PBS L versus the quadrinate
liposome
um treated animals but when we dug down
and looked more deeply
we found that when you we looked closely
there was an increase in the amount of
neutrophils
in our animals that had
um they put that lacked pleural
macrophages
so having a lack of plural macrophages
led to an increase in the amount of
neutrophils in the lung and as I had
mentioned earlier one of the things that
we do see in the literature mentioned
often is that when there are increa when
there is a high amount of neutrophils in
the lung that is often associated with
um severe influenza
we also found that by look by
um doing a license we found that the the
plural cytokines were different as well
we had increases in
interferon gamma tnf Alpha and mcp1 in
our animals that lacked plural
macrophages
so overall plural macrophage depletion
causes increased Mutual flow influx into
the lung during influenza virus
infection
so to summarize
I showed you today that we used whole
long transcriptomic data and
bioinformatic tools to identify immune
drivers of influenza outcomes
so we were able to actually take
transcriptional data and use it to
generate hypotheses
and our data indicate that plural
macrophages migrate to the lung during
influenza virus infection
PM macro no so plural macrophage
depletion does not affect long viral
loads so it's not affecting viral
replication
what it does impact disease outcomes so
it does
increase so pleural macrophages are
important for disease outcomes because
depleting them
increases the disease severity by
leading to an influx of neutrophils into
the lung
and finally plural macrophages improve
influenza outcomes
and so I'd encourage you if you are
interested in learning more about this
project
um to check out our preprint on
bioarchive that we posted
um last month and we're currently
um working to submit this formally
and I'd like to acknowledge the people
that made this happen this project was
primarily driven by James Stumpf in my
lab and I'd also like to thank the
members of my lab the nire lab
and remember
at UC Riverside as well as others at um
UW medicine and Tel Aviv University
and I look forward to hearing your
questions and comments thank you so much
for listening have a good day